the Pawn Stars fandom continues to reel
from the tragic and shocking news at
Adam Harrison Rick Harrison's second son
passed away at the age of 39 due to an
overdose reactions from both celebrities
and fans alike continue to pour in Rick
Harrison first responded to his son's
passing on Instagram posting a photo of
them together along with a broken heart
emoji with a caption you will always be
in my heart I love you Adam underneath
Donald Trump junr offered his
condolences writing quote I'm so sorry
man Rick Harrison has long been known
for his conservative belief and publicly
supported Donald Trump in the 2020
presidential election Sons of Anarchy
and Mayan's MC star amilio Rivera also
replied underneath Harrison's post
saying rest in peace my condolences to
you and the Familia popular YouTube
personality and prankster Dennis roie
offered his condolences and expressed
his hope that the Harrison family can
find peace during this difficult time
doar star Bernard tin brinka likewise
expressed his sympathies prominent Las
Vegas businessman Richard wil replied to
Harrison's tribute with a heartfelt
reply he wrote I'm so sorry to hear
about Adam may he rest in peace and God
bless you and your family my friend
former Pussycat Doll singer Ka Jones
expressed her quote deepest condolences
Joe Pags a conservative radio talk show
host based out of San Antonio wrote
sorry to hear about this Rick sending
prayers Danielle manaro longtime co-host
of the Elvis Duran in the morning show
radio program also gave Harrison her
condolences she wrote along with heart
emoji sending you lots of love and
prayers other members of the Harrison
family have also made public statements
since Adam's passing longtime Pawn Stars
Stand Out Corey Harrison Rick Harrison's
first son and Adam's older brother also
took the Instagram following his
siblings tragic passing the pawn shop
veteran posted a picture of him holding
a childhood photo of him and his brother
playing inside a bathtub the caption
underneath reads I will always love you
Bubba in a public statement the Harrison
family expressed their need for privacy
during this troubling time per TMZ her
family is extremely saddened by the
death of Adam we ask for privacy as we
grieve his loss when I connected to his
father's V Vegas Empire like his brother
Adam had a career path that strayed far
away from Pawn Stars the tragic loss
clearly Cuts deep for longtime fans of
the Harrison fam's televised bargaining
exploits the belov series which has been
airing on the History Channel since 2009
has produced over 20 Seasons with its
latest concluding in June 2023 aside
from the aforementioned celebrities
scores of pawn star fans took to social
media to send their well wishes to Rick
and Cory Harrison a number of Instagram
users mentioned that They too had lost
loved ones to substance use one user
wrote in the comment section of Rick
Harrison's tribute post to his late son
Jesus man I lost my son the same way in
August another commented I'm so sorry
that you're a member of this club we
don't know each other but I'm here for
you and your family wishing you peace
another commenter claimed to have
personally encountered Adam and shared
their Recollections of his positive
demeanor they wrote love you buddy met
at him a few times and what a sweet
person thinking of you buddy similarly
Cory's post honoring his brother was
flooded with condolences from fans all
over the world including one user who
wrote sorry for your loss Corey I've
lost a few Brothers myself and it's
tough I'll be thinking of you guys fans
continue to flood Rick with messages of
support since news broke about Adam's
death I'm so sorry Rick you bring so
many people joy and the least I can do
is send you prayers in your time of
grief if you are anyone you know needs
help with addiction issues help is
available visit the Substance Abuse and
Mental Health Services Administration
website or contact samsa National helpl
line at 1 1800 662 help
[Music]